lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
familiarizarnos con la prueba de la
segunda derivada y bueno antes de llegar
a la parte central de este vídeo quiero
que obtengamos una sensación intuitiva
de lo que nos está diciendo la prueba de
la segunda derivada así que para eso voy
a dibujar los ejes por aquí supongamos
que este es mi eje x y este por acá va a
ser mi eje y este es mi hijo y este es
mi
y digamos que tengo una función que se
ve más o menos así
esta va a ser mi función algo más o
menos así y bueno si observas esta
función más o menos tiene un máximo
relativo por aquí en el valor de xy
wallace m es decir este es el punto y
coma efe de ccm así que por acá tenemos
en x el valor de ce y visualmente
podemos ver que tenemos un punto local
máximo aquí tenemos un máximo relativo y
entonces podemos usar nuestras
herramientas de cálculo para pensar qué
está pasando aquí
en este punto bien una cosa que sabemos
es que la pendiente de la recta tangente
al menos en la forma en la que he
dibujado esto la pendiente de la recta
tangente es igual a cero entonces
podemos decir que f prima de c
esto debe de ser igual a 0 y otra cosa
que podemos ver es que tenemos una
concavidad hacia abajo en una vecindad
claro alrededor de este valor x igual
hace entonces noten que nuestra
pendiente está constantemente
decreciendo empieza siendo muy positiva
es menos positiva aún menos positiva
luego se vuelve a cero luego se vuelve
negativa más negativa y aún más negativa
por lo tanto podemos decir que f
be prima de sem esto va a hacer algo
menor que es 0 está decreciendo y ojo
todavía no he hecho ninguna prueba
matemática a fondo pero parece ser que
tenemos algo si tenemos un punto crítico
donde x es igual a cm entonces
efe prima de cm es igual a 0 y además
vemos que hay la segunda derivada es
menor que cero entonces intuitivamente
vamos a tener un valor
y ahora bien podemos ir en la situación
contraria imagínate que yo me tomo una
función que se vea más o menos así en
donde tengamos un punto local mínimo
también en el mismo valor para xy
wallace m déjame ponerlo estamos en el
mismo valor estamos en el mismo valor y
aquí tenemos nuestro punto local mínimo
y entonces nuestra primera derivada
también va a ser igual a cero ya que la
pendiente de la recta tangente aquí en
este punto sigue siendo cero entonces
aquí tenemos que f prima de x esto va a
seguir siendo cero pero ahora observa en
este segundo caso tenemos una concavidad
hacia arriba y la pendiente está
creciendo constantemente tenemos una
forma de un tazón que abre hacia arriba
entonces aquí en el caso en el que
tenemos un mínimo relativo podemos decir
que
nuestra segunda derivada va a ser mayor
que 0 lo voy a poner aquí nuestra
segunda derivada en este punto se me
tiene que ser mayor que 0 y con esto
visualmente vemos que tenemos un mínimo
relativo y entonces esta intención que
acabamos de crear con optimismo que nos
dice de la prueba de la segunda derivada
bueno lo que nos dice lo siguiente
imagínate que estás trabajando con una
función doblemente diferenciable eso
significa que durante cualquier
intervalo puedes encontrar su primera y
su segunda derivada definidas y digamos
que en un punto x igual a c
encontramos que su primera derivada es
igual a cero así que la pendiente de la
recta tangente es igual a cero y no sólo
eso la derivada existe en una vecindad
alrededor de este punto x igual a cm y
bueno la mayoría de las funciones con
las que trabajamos es diferenciable en
cm y tiende a ser diferenciables en una
vecindad
de ese valor de ese y luego supongo que
la segunda derivada existe es doblemente
diferenciable ya lo dijimos ahora bien
podríamos estar trabajando con un punto
máximo o con un punto mínimo o podríamos
no saber con lo que estamos trabajando
podría no ser ni un punto máximo ni un
punto mínimo pero usando la prueba de la
segunda derivada si sacamos la segunda
derivada y vemos que esa segunda
derivada es menor que cero como en este
caso que tengo aquí entonces lo que
podemos asegurar es que estamos
trabajando con un máximo relativo con un
punto máximo relativo en x igual a cm es
decir estamos en este caso en el caso
que teníamos en un inicio ahora sí
nuestra segunda derivada es mayor que
cero entonces estaríamos en este segundo
caso en este caso de aquí tenemos una
concavidad hacia arriba y en el fondo
del tazón es donde la pendiente es igual
a cero tenemos un punto mínimo
y si nuestra segunda derivada es igual a
cero entonces no podemos decir nada al
respecto
estamos inconclusos no sabemos lo que
realmente está pasando en ese punto por
lo tanto no podemos hacer ninguna
afirmación sólida y bueno ya que sabemos
cómo funciona la prueba de la segunda
derivada qué te parece si hacemos un
pequeño y rápido ejemplo solo para ver
si esto está funcionando bien digamos no
sé que tengo una función h
sabemos que h de 8 esto es igual a 5 ok
por otra parte sabemos que h prima de 8
esto es igual a 0 y también sabemos que
a chevy prima de 8 la segunda derivada
evaluada en 8 esto es igual a menos 4
ahora la pregunta es la siguiente dada
esta información podemos decir que el
punto 8.5 este punto de aquí es un
mínimo relativo es un máximo relativo o
esté inconcluso dejan adaptarlo este
punto de aquí es un punto máximo
relativo mínimo relativo o simplemente
es inconcluso y bueno como siempre te
invito a pausar el vídeo y que lo
pienses un rato
intenta encontrar la respuesta bueno
nosotros estamos suponiendo que es una
función doblemente diferenciable y
pienso que es muy prudente suponer eso y
por el bien de nuestro problema vamos a
suponer que la derivada existe en una
vecindad alrededor de x igual a 8 bien
para este ejemplo c es igual a 8
entonces el punto 85 definitivamente
está en la curva y también sabemos que
la derivada es igual a cero así que
estamos trabajando con
un punto el cual nos da algunos de estos
tres escenarios y además sabemos que la
segunda derivada es menor que cero esto
es muy importante sabemos que la segunda
derivada de 8
esto es menor que cero y que nos está
diciendo esto bueno lo que nos está
diciendo es que caemos en este escenario
que tenemos aquí así que solo con la
información que nos están dando podemos
decir que el punto 85 es un valor máximo
relativo es decir estamos trabajando con
un punto máximo relativo y eso está muy
bien ahora si de alguna manera nos
dijeran que la segunda derivada no fuera
igual a cero entonces podemos concluir
que no tenemos la suficiente información
que es inconcluso y si por alguna razón
nos dijeran que la segunda derivada
mayor que 0 entonces qué haríamos en
este caso estaríamos trabajando con un
valor mínimo relativo en bueno x igual a